ja ozapft is das würde es eigentlich
heute in münchen heißen die wiesn es
abgesagt gefeiert wird trotzdem
und wir wollen live zu meinem kollegen
ins münchner hofbräuhaus schalten wo
jetzt geben doch o zapft wird hier sind
die bürger genau man kann es sehen
der hof porsche toppt an michael müller
der hier um punkt 12 uhr mit zwei
doppelschlägen das fass angestoßen hat
er hat hier im vorfeld gesagt hat er
hofft dass er nur zwei schläge braucht
der erste solche ritzen der zweite soll
sitzen damit die fotografen auch ein
schönes bild haben und jetzt wird hier
feinstes bier ausgeschenkt aus dem
holzfass und keine zimmer rüber
schwenken hier sitzen schon ein paar
leute kamera schauen dass sie alles
verfolgen
oben die kapelle wie gedacht jetzt läuft
das bier
wir sehen in münchen die lage ist nicht
ganz so wie wir sie kennen normalerweise
würde der oberbürgermeister um punkt
zwölf devisen eröffnen und anzapfen und
hier sehen wir jetzt die bilder live aus
dem münchner hofbräuhaus es wirtschaft
und zwar bei der gaststätten wiesen 54
gaststätten sind daran beteiligt unter
hohen sicherheitsauflagen soll jetzt
hier das bier fließen
wie das aussehen wird und was auf der
theresienwiese los ist wo die wissen ja
eigentlich stattfinden sollte wollen wir
uns genauer anschauen mein kollege jakob
mel ist in münchen vor ort er ist auf
der theresienwiese und kelkheim mein
kollege ist im hofbräuhaus und zwar mit
dem chef des münchner hofbräuhauses
haben vorhin die bilder gesehen dort
wurde zumindest o'zapft ja als erstes
mal die frage jakob wie sieht es denn
auf der theresienwiese aus also dort wo
die wiesn eigentlich hätte stattfinden
sollen
ja es ist hier sage ich mal ein eher
trauriges bild es sind hier ein paar
menschen die in tracht hier sind es ist
ja alkoholverbot auf der wiesn extra
verhängt worden weil man angst hatte
dass sich private partys hier vielleicht
zum anstich versammeln
die polizei kontrolliert aber bisher ist
alles ruhig ein paar minuten pünktlich
um 12 haben die menschen auf der treppe
hinter mir jedenfalls heruntergezählt
und symbolisch angezapft in münchen
steigen ja die korona zahlen auch weiter
an was ist in der stadt jetzt zur
schönsten wiesen zeit eigentlich
überhaupt noch erlaubt diese frage noch
mal an dich jakob bevor wir dann auch
noch live ins münchner hofbräuhaus
schauen wollen
ja es ist folgendes erlaubt die stadt
hat für gewisse hotspots für den
heutigen tag ist dass auch die
theresienwiese und andere gärtnerplatz
isar auen und andere plätze wo sich
viele menschen gesammelt haben
versammelt haben ein alkoholkonsumverbot
ausgesprochen ab 23 uhr darf dort nicht
mehr
alkohol getrunken werden bis ein wert
wieder unter 35 gehalten ist
die meisten so wie ich das sehe halten
sich daran
mal schauen wie es weitergeht
ja ich sag das eingangs gefeiert wird ja
trotzdem wie man in münchen sagt
zumindest bis unter anderem im münchner
hofbräuhaus und dort ist jetzt mein
kollege karl heim und erst zusammen mit
dem chef des münchner hofbräuhauses wir
haben eingangs die bilder vom anstich
gesehen und jetzt möchte ich auch das
wort übergeben an die beiden
herrschaften mit einem herzlichen grüß
gott das chaos aus münchen hier war doch
o'zapft ist um pünktlich um 12 uhr hat
der europachef doktor michael müller mit
zwei schlägen das fass angezapft herr
müller wie ist das in diesem jahr
diese mini diesen die da jetzt
ausschließen wie fühlt sich das an im
vergleich zum original
es ist jetzt zu sagen wir mal kein
vergleich aber es ist doch schön weil
irgendwo lassen wir uns unsere
lebensfreude unser lebensgefühl nicht
nehmen und über 200 jahren war es ja eh
lima hat er nicht auf der wiesn draußen
gefeiert sondern war ist wieder
zurückkehren in die wirtschaft hat den
wirtshäusern gefeiert und so ist es auch
also ist es irgendwo ein jubiläum kein
judas und es aber doch entschieden
normalerweise ist der vorfreude aus der
dafür bekannt dass das immer proppenvoll
ist wie viele menschen passen jetzt in
den festsaal reihen zu keiner zeit und
wie viele bären es sonst also wir haben
jetzt ungefähr 400 will über 400 leute
die der trainer
ansonsten ist das doppelte also wir
haben extra locker bestuhlt damit wir
den auflagen entsprechend gerecht werden
sie haben die auflagen angesprochen
welche auch lang gibt es denn
ja wir haben als erstes die
hygienevorschriften das heißt also die
masken aufsetzen wenn wir uns bewegen
wenn du in der gruppe sind wir müssen
die abstände einhalten wir beim sitzen
die allen abstände einhalten und was für
uns natürlich auch ganz ganz wichtig ist
werden
unser wirtshaus wiesen darf auf den
bänken nicht gestanden und getanzt
ich glaube das können die münchner
gerade eben noch zu verkraften noch ein
noch eine letzte frage wie viel bier wie
normalerweise verkauft im hofbräuhaus
normal über das ganze jahr verteilt kein
corona ist wenn wir kein chor oder dann
verkaufen wir ungefähr zwei millionen
liter hier im oberhaus und wie viel
steuer werden weiß ich jetzt nicht genau
aber wir sind glücklich dass unsere
freunde unsere fans unsere gäste
wiederkommen sie gekommen wieder zu uns
und auch wenn jetzt die
hygienevorschriften irgendwo ich sag's
mal vielleicht nicht zu bequem sind aber
es ist bequemer oder angenehmer eine
maske zu tragen also irgendwo krank zu
sein und eine sauerstoffmaske zu tragen
mit diesen worten des europachefs dr
michael müller zurück nach berlin
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schaue ich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren